de ma naissance à mes 6 ans avant l'âge
de avant la naissance pardon de mon
petit frère de 16 ans
tout se passait on va dire correct
après pas totalement on habitait dans
une maison squattée de ma naissance à
mes 6 ans milieu des cafards des
insectes tout ce qui se passe dans une
maison souhaité ensuite on déménage dans
une nouvelle maison plus grande au moins
les filles sont séparés des garçons et
voilà la venue de mon petit frère de 16
ans et à partir de ce moment tout
déraille
les violences commencent les violences
physiques les violences verbales
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé qui avait quoi
comme violence il y avait des coups de
poing des coups de pied pourquoi pour
rien
peut-être pour nous servir mais
peut-être pour eux c'est sûr que c'est
pas ça va être parce que on n'a pas obéi
après la première remarque c'est parce
que on a pris un gâteau au bout de trois
fois qui nous entier non ça va être
puisqu'on a refusé d'avoir fait le
ménage ça va être parce que on a refusé
d'avoir de vouloir aller faire les
courses à moins 5 dehors ou à 40 degrés
l'été
ça va être voilà pour des raisons quoi
comme on se dit coup de poing c'était
des coups de poings des coups de pied
des coups de bâton j'ai vu j'ai vu mon
petit frère de 16 ans se faire jeter un
casque de scooter de plein fouet par par
mon père
mon petit frère tombé par terre ça
respiration coupé de devant les yeux de
ma mère j'ai vu des coups de balai des
coups de raclette j'ai reçu aussi ses
couleurs
des coups de chaussures de sécurité en
fait tout ce qui pouvait prendre comme
projet que tu pourras bien nous faire
mal
il le faisait après il y a aussi un de
mes oncles j'ai vu taper devant devant
les yeux les yeux de mes parents
lui mettre des coups de tête à plusieurs
reprises parce que tout simplement il
homosexuel donc votre père a tapé votre
oncle non non non
frère aussi ouais tout simplement parce
que homosexuel j'ai vu mes parents
oui voilà plusieurs reprises de devant
mes parents assis dans le fauteuil en
train en train de regarder la scène et
j'ai dû une nouvelle fois intervenir
physiquement pour pour arrêter mon oncle
vous avez fait quoi
j'ai essayé de lui mettre des coups de
poing il m'a rendu les coups j'avais 12
ans donc avec ma force de 12 ans à lui
de
ce moment là il y avait 27 30 ans je
faisais pas le poids bien sûr mon grand
frère non plus
j'ai vu on s'est on s'est fait aussi
venir violemment
c'était des trois quatre heures à genoux
même le sol
on ne sortait plus nos genoux si on
avait le malheur de tomber si par terre
c'était reparti pour des points de pied
des coups de bâtons tout ce qui était
possible pour nous faire mal mais
surtout surtout ne pas laisser de coup
qui marque ne pas laisser de coup qui
marque et aujourd'hui ça sert
aujourd'hui ça sert parce que grâce à ça
la justice a des doutes la justice mais
non cause toutes nos paroles
après nombre témoignages de donne mes
frères dieu de la sœur de ma mère qui a
vu certaines scènes insultent homophobes
insultent tout court violence punition
mais pour eux comme comme il y a peu de
coups marquants comme il y a pas de
cicatrice comme il y a pas de vidéo je
suis désolé aujourd'hui auprès de la
justice j'ai pas filmé mon petit frère
ou une de mes petites en train de se
faire frapper j'aurais peut-être dû
entrer les coups les coups pour
qu'aujourd'hui
tout ce qu'on dit c'est pas faux alors
on va voir dans un instant la réaction
du procureur qui vous a fait énormément
de peine donc vous allez avoir dans
quelques instants juste rien donc
comment vous faisiez pour avoir une vie
normale vous alliez en cours vous
faisiez une vie normale le soir vous
rentriez avec la la peur au ventre le
comment ça se passait on avait tout
simplement pas une vie normale pour une
vie d'enfant normal déjà on a les on
allait à l'école quand quand mes parents
décidaient de se lever ah oui il
travaillait pas il travaille pas
de 7 ans faisait que dormir à l'école
parce que il ne pouvait pas dormir à la
maison à force d'en prendre les cris des
filles attachés qui veulent tout
simplement descendre pour aller pour
être en liberté comme un enfant normal
justement qu'est-ce qui se passait parce
que ça on en a pas parlé c'est
incroyable c'est quoi cette histoire des
filles attachées tout simplement c'est
que pour ma mère qui ne fait rien de ces
jours-là parfumer des cigarettes et être
sur son téléphone elle ne peut pas
surveiller deux petites de petites de 5
à 2 ans elle ne Paul elle ne peut pas
les laisser libre pour elle c'est
impossible elle ne peut pas les changer
on les change une fois par jour on est
petit et ça c'est
les petites sont attachées 23 heures sur
24 quand ils sont attachés comment mais
il y a il y a déjà le harnais de
sécurité de base plus l'accord du
peignoir qui sert de
chaîne comme un comme un prisonnier pour
pas
j'aimais depuis et ça fait donc 5 ans et
7 enfin 5 ans et 3 mois 3 ans c'est ça
mais il commence ça vers leur un an
d'accord une des petites quatre ans pour
l'autre des deux qui est attachée 23
heures sur 24 non c'est après il y a pas
eu que cette scène là comme j'appelle ça
de la séquestration j'ai eu une de mes
petits frères qui sont aujourd'hui âgés
de de 7 et 10 ans qu'ils ont été aussi
eu attachés pas sur des chaises autres
ils avaient le droit la poussette la
poussette 23h sur 24 peut changer leurs
fesses
même fonctionnement mais là on les
attacher à la poussette et au fauteuil
surtout pour pas qu'ils arrivent à
s'échapper comme comme les filles
aujourd'hui donc qu'est-ce qui se
passait au quotidien ce que vous mangiez
à votre faim est-ce que qu'est-ce qui se
passait ce qu'il y avait des moments
normaux dans cette famille ou jamais
manger on mangeait tous les jours manger
on pouvait manger mais certaines pas
certainement pas aux heures adéquates
c'est à dire un enfant ne doit pas
manger l'après-midi quand ils vont pas à
l'école quand on les met pas 15 heures
de l'après-midi un enfant doit pas doit
pas manger à 23 heures le soir il doit
être déjà dans son lit en train de
dormir depuis un certain moment on
entend bien avoisine qui dit que elle
entend les enfants jouent à 21h elle
essaie de défendre mes parents et leur
temps les enfants je vois 21h dehors
quand elle met son enfant a couché
c'est leur seul moment de liberté 21h
aller jouer un petit peu dehors c'est
pas à 21h qu'on met sur son enfant à
jouer dehors
qu'est-ce qui se passait qu'est-ce qui
se passait d'autre de ce qu'on appelle
maintenant cette maison la maison de
l'horreur qu'est-ce qui se passait
d'autre au quotidien tout simplement la
petite aujourd'hui d'attacher aussi un
cancer à l'oeil
un cancer à l'oeil et suivi normalement
dans dans deux hôpital c'est de l'île de
Lens j'aimerais bien que la justice
demande un récapitulatif de présence de
ces rendez-vous
pour voir que ça et elle allait pas au
rendez-vous
vous allez sur de rendez-vous sur cinq
mes parents ne sont pas tirs du permis
de conduire je leur ai proposé mathémat
de fois de les amener à Lille qui a 20
km de chez nous
souvent il me répondait non c'est pas la
peine c'est pas un rendez-vous important
une ou décollerons juste le rendez-vous
ça pouvait aller comme ça décalé décalé
décalé après toutes ces violences toute
le mot tout le mot phobie avec avec mon
grand frère aîné
c'est quoi comme
tout simplement tout simplement des
insultes de la plus petite la plus
grande que qu'un enfant peut entendre
les coûts les coûts tout simplement
parce que voilà il est en gros comme ils
appellent [ __ ] on accepte pas de ça dans
notre famille c'est pas normal du coup
on va le taper en haut pour qui pour
qu'il arrête de l'être simplement on
n'accepte pas
aujourd'hui
c'est le petit c'est le petit de 6 ans
refusait de dormir à 23h et qu'il
faisait que de bouger dans dans la
maison dans lui mettait des fessées
jusqu'à temps qu'il se fatigue jusqu'à
temps qu'il se fatigue
cet enfant là
cet enfant-là est l'un des enfants qui a
pris certainement le plus de coups
aujourd'hui il y a 7 ans il est en
sécurité
grâce à mes deux frères à moi
aujourd'hui il y a en sécurité je sais
qu'il prendra plus de coups
mais les scènes restent en tête et ça
folle que la justice ne comprend pas
c'est incroyable on va en parler dans un
instant vous allez voir la réaction et
c'est ça m'a désespéré moi de voir la
réaction procureur aujourd'hui pour vous
Bryan je sais pas comment on peut douter
de cette affaire Brian
vous avez 21 ans qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé
qu'est-ce qui a fait que vous avez
décidé de parler et d'arrêter ce
massacre parce que c'est un massacre
tout simplement parce qu'aujourd'hui je
suis je suis pas pas d'une petite de 20
mots aujourd'hui je vois que vous
habitiez vous habitiez où en fait là
vous avez quitter le domicile je sais
pas qui c'était le domicile
mes frères aujourd'hui donc ok ok et que
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé parce que
c'est toi qui a donné l'alerte après une
dispute avec ton père c'est ça en fait
c'était c'était lundi la semaine d'avant
après que mon petit frère s'est fait
taper par trois personnes du domicile
dans mon père il y avait qui dans ce
domicile qui avait ton père ta mère et
avec ton oncle aussi non non
la scène de mon oncle c'était avant
c'était encore on n'était plus jeune lol
les trois personnes qui ont tapé mon
petit frère jette de saison mon père de
44 ans mon beau-frère de 20 ans et ma
sœur de 19 ans donc ta sœur design de
tes sœurs qui a pris feu les causes pour
tes pas ouais c'est ça aujourd'hui
elle dit que les petits lui manquent
d'être en foyer mais elle est en aucun
cas de notre côté aujourd'hui elle fait
aucune démarche quand mes parents alors
qu'il y a quelques mois elle m'a envoyé
des messages qu'elle voulait déposer
plainte qu'elle pouvait plus de vivre et
de voir ce que ce qu'elle avait vécu
aujourd'hui et donc à la suite de cette
dispute à la suite de cette dispute et
de cette bagarre surtout parce qu'il y a
eu
il a quel âge
c'était dimanche dernier après lui avoir
mis des multiples coups j'ai décidé
encore une fois de m'interposer tu étais
dans t'étais à la maison ce jour
parce que tu sais à la maison de
l'horreur pourquoi tu t'es revenu
c'était pour être avec tes frères pour
être avec ta famille parce que tu as
envie de les aider parce que c'est vrai
qu'on se dit pas il y a des réunions
familiales le dimanche on a c'est vrai
que voilà toi tu avais quitté le
domicile mais tu étais revenu dimanche
on est souvent on peut les voir je
venais souvent voir mes petits frères et
mes petites heures aujourd'hui j'ai 10
frères et sœurs
si aujourd'hui le petit de 6 ans après
un nouveau coup si aujourd'hui le petit
de 6 ans n'était pas tombé sur les coups
si aujourd'hui le petit saison n'était
pas encore mis dehors je vivais avec une
inquiétude incroyable tu pouvais pas les
laisser cette maison
j'ai fait de multiples travaux pour
qu'il soit c'est pas possible dans des
dans des hygiène normal parce que
c'était trop déploré mais un minimum
strict j'ai essayé de prendre tout tous
mes frères et sœurs au moins plusieurs
fois mon domicile pour qui qui s'échappe
de sa mentalement et donc il y a eu
cette énième dispute et là qu'est-ce que
tu décides de faire il y a eu cette
dispute après tous les coups distribués
après que j'arrive à séparer en mettant
aussi des coups pour enlever mon petit
frère de l'homme donc je décide le
lendemain déjà toute la nuit je passe la
nuit à pleurer parce que je mets des je
mets des coups devant ma fille devant
moi qui ne doit pas qui ne doit pas voir
ça le nom de ma vie me réveille je me
dis que c'est stop c'est fini que ils
n'auront plus aucune chance de de faire
ce qu'ils ont fait à mes petits frères
et sœurs j'appelle donc le service des
assistantes sociales de Lens
je leur explique tout ce qu'on a vécu
j'arrive plus tout ce que j'ai vu toutes
les toutes les scènes il y a eu aussi
des scènes sexuelles l'homophobie les
violences physiques verbales
c'est-à-dire des sexuels quel type de
j'ai déjà vu mon père et mon oncle se
montrerait leur pénis l'un l'autre à
travers la webcam c'était du temps
d'aimer c'est normal dans les années
2010 il pensait peut-être pas que
j'allais m'en souvenir encore
aujourd'hui mais dix ans plus tard plus
de 10 ans ça les images quand j'en parle
le circule encore dans ma tête on voit
on voit les petits dans la maison jouer
avec leur joint intime parce que c'est
pas rangé c'est normal c'est rigolo
donc j'ai décidé d'expliquer tout ça à
l'assistante sociale la personne
derrière le téléphone est choquée et
choqué elle me dit qu'on comprend pas
que des enfants peuvent vivre dans ces
conditions elle souhaite comme tout le
monde beaucoup de courage mais merci
d'avoir fait ce signalement vous savez
vos petits frères et soeurs merci à vous
mais j'espère que vous allez les sortir
de là plus vite possible car il ne
peuvent plus vivre dedans on va être
appelé pour un drame
il y a une vidéo qui a fait énormément
parler c'est la vidéo du procureur le
procureur de la République assemblée
minimiser tout ça et refuse de parler de
maison de l'horreur regardez
ça me paraît qualificatif tout à fait
exagéré on a à faire à des manquements
certains on a affaire à des manques
d’hygiène des carences éducatifs on n'a
pas de traces de coups sur les enfants
on n'a pas d'enfants couverts
d'excrément
alors ça c'est une des vidéos il y a la
tente aussi
ta tante qui explique que tes parents ne
sont pas comme ça tu attendes c'est la
femme de l'oncle qui qui battait
également donc qui frappait également
le jour le papa avait un rendez-vous et
le moment s'occuper de ses enfants voilà
mais elle s'occupait un par un elle peut
pas s'occuper du bébé du dernier né et
des deux autres filles et ce sont des
enfants de bas âge qui si marche par
terre peuvent se cogner aussi et la
maman était en train de donner le
biberon à son autre petit dernier sa
petite donc elle pouvait pas s'occuper
de tous ses enfants en même temps c'est
normal c'est des parents qui aiment
leurs enfants il y a pas eu autant de
mal que ce que disent les médias
quand tu vois c'est c'est de témoignages
je vais d'abord revenir sur le
témoignage de ma tante pour mettre les
choses au clair avec elle alors deux
jours avant son
interview on va dire son témoignage elle
m'invite chez elle au soir alors que
lorsque mes parents sont en garde à vue
elle me dit nouvelle fois j'ai pas
beaucoup de courage nous malheureusement
on n'a jamais osé rien dire on a on a vu
des choses je ne voulais plus ramener
mes enfants j'étais parents parce que
ils voyaient des choses je demandais à
mes à mes enfants de fermer les yeux
quand il passait devant les petites
attachés pleines d'excréments deux jours
après je vois je vois ce témoignage j'ai
été choqué j'ai été choqué mais
pas encore pas encore assez parce que
hier matin mon réveil je reçois un
message de cette même tente qui m'envoie
un message en gros pour me dire qu'elle
regrette d'avoir fait un faux témoignage
voilà que ce message Bryan j'ai une
erreur en témoignant à la télé crois-moi
bien que je m'en veux je suis à vos
côtés directifié le tir par le remord de
la culpabilité en allant au commissariat
pour vous soutenir s'il faut que je
témoigne de tribunal je le ferai les
médias nous ont mis pression et disait
que ça allait faire taire les médias
c'était pour nous mettre à couvert dont
oncle ressemble à son frère et nos
enfants et notre travail voilà donc elle
dit que c'est fou tu as donné ta fourni
ce SMS à la production c'est ça à cause
de ces gens là aujourd'hui que l'État va
douter que l'État va douter parce que
ils remettent tout toutes nos
enfants qui sont vaincus qui sont vécus
c'est à cause de ces gens là où j'ai
aussi une autre tente qui a témoigner
une tente que j'ai vu trois fois dans ma
vie une tente qui connaît l'existence de
quatre enfants sur 10 dans le foyer
une tente que je me souvenais plus de
son visage et c'est à cause de ces
gens-là qu'aujourd'hui on a des
procureurs en France qui prennent en
gros la défense de mes parents
aujourd'hui
c'est incroyable aujourd'hui Ryan
il y a aussi les voisins qui ont dit
qu'il n'avaient pas vu de manquement qui
n'avait pas
vu qui n'est pas entendu de de bruit de
violence
puisque tu leur réponds les voisins je
comprends les voisins je comprends parce
que c'était tellement bien organisé
c'est ça ça se faisait quand quand la
porte était fermée
nous malgré que on a eu des on va dire
des parents même si pour moi aujourd'hui
je ne veux plus entendre ce mot de ma
bouche en voyant leur tête toi ce n'est
plus ce ne sont pas je ne porte plus
aucun amour je porte de la tristesse de
la haine ce qu'aujourd'hui après tout ce
qu'ils ont fait aucune excuse aucun
remord
donc les voisins je les comprends je
reviens sur ça parce que la maison se
faisait fermer nous quand on voyait les
voisins comme il dit c'était toujours
bonjour c'est toujours un sourire et et
Bryan il y a Justine qui est à côté de
toi t'as pas de merci Justine d'être là
vous avez une petite île 20 mois tous
les deux Justine est-ce qu'il t'en
parlais Bryan ce qui te parlais de tout
ça tu étais au courant de tout alors
j'étais au point parce qu'il m'a parlé
mais aussi parce que je l'ai vu de
moi-même en fait
au début de notre relation je voyais
rien parce qu'il se cachait très bien en
fin de compte mais une fois que j'étais
reparti chez moi à mon domicile chez mes
parents mais que lui était là-bas et
qu'on était au téléphone j'entendais des
insultes de la plus petite à la plus
grande une fois j'ai pas eu de ses
nouvelles pendant au moins une heure
parce que justement il se faisait
insulter de tous les noms et en fait
petit à petit ça c'est dégradé c'était
des coups des insultes c'est en fait je
savais pas que la violence physique il y
a aussi psychologique
parce que un moment je dis tu l'as dit
il faut il il faut que tu ailles voilà
voir des gens qui qui s'occupent de
cette affaire et qui vous sortent de
cette maison en horreur cette discussion
il était persuadé que ses parents
allaient changer parce que à cette
époque il leur portait beaucoup d'amour
parce que comme tu as dit tout à l'heure
je n'ai plus d'amour pour eux parce que
tu les as aimé tes parents oui malgré ça
ça restait pour moi mes parents et
j'aurais jamais imaginé à chaud je sais
pas s'il y a des enfants qui imaginent
un jour par tes plate contre leurs
parents aujourd'hui c'est par tout ce
que je suis en train de faire le combo
que je suis en train de mener pour
sauver mes frères et sœurs
aujourd'hui vouloir mes parents en
prison je pense pas que un enfant
voilà j'ai toujours espéré que un jour
cela change un jour cela change
pardon des mois ces derniers mois je
parlais à mes frères et soeurs il va
falloir agir parce que parce que ça ne
change pas parce que en fait malgré
toutes les espoirs malgré qu'on essaie
de les aider ça ne change pas il y a pas
un grand frère ou qui s'est dit à un
moment moi je vais parce que on voit
qu'il a eu énormément violenté insulté
est-ce qu'à un moment il a pas dit je
vais aller tout dire parce qu'il faut
que ça c'est bien sûr mon grand frère
avait été voir l'assistante sociale de
son lycée il lui a tout expliqué ce qui
vivait à la maison tout tout tout tout
l'assistante sociale décide de déposer
une plaque pour lui au commissariat de
notre région c'était le commissariat
on reçoit donc un coup de téléphone de
la brigade des mineurs juste avant de
partir mon père savait vous savez ce
qu'il faisait savait que c'était mon
frère qui qui avait dit quelque chose
parce que mon frère n'était pas rentré
de la journée
donc comme d'habitude il nous brise il
nous brûle il nous dit tout simplement
que si on dit ce qui se passe à la
maison si on dit les cours on reçoit
c'est on dit que que les frères et
soeurs se font assez mais de coup de
poing reçoit vos temps d'insultes tout
ça et ben tout simplement on va être
placé on va être placé en foyer et en
famille d'accueil on va tout simplement
tout séparer il nous raconter le foyer
comme l'horreur simplement comme comme
ça se passait chez nous en fait tout
simplement ça pourrait pas être plus
horreur que chez vous à ce moment là on
s'en rendait pas compte car on avait
vécu que ça donc il nous racontait ça
encore pire t'en parler à des potes non
tout ça
tout à l'heure j'ai encore vu un ami
dans la rue qui m'a dit pourquoi tu ne
nous en a pas parlé
c'est je vivais comme ça en fait c'était
tout simplement normal non à part ma
famille de temps en temps qui me disait
que c'était moi normal maison que mes
tantes qui qui voyait ce qui se passait
mais qui réagissait pas et du coup on a
on arrive au commissariat pour pour mon
grand frère comme on était tous bien
bien checkés
tout simplement au commissariat en niant
en niant c'est fait en disant que c'est
vrai que c'était pas vrai et que c'était
tout simplement nous en gros qu'on était
tout simplement pas des enfants de coeur
on était passage à la maison que nos
parents avaient du courage
donc tu n'osais pas j'osais pas les
mettre les maîtres dans le pétrin quitte
à nous sacrifier
Justine
[Musique]
est-ce que
le voilà Brian aujourd'hui ça va il va
devoir se reconstruire c'est vrai que
voilà c'est c'est voilà il a envie voilà
du meilleur aussi pour ses frères et
sœurs aujourd'hui vous avez une petite
fille
aujourd'hui voilà Brian au quotidien
est-ce qu'il arrive à vivre normalement
parce qu'on le voit
il arrive à dormir il arrive à vivre une
vie normale il arrive à voilà je sais
que vous avez une petite fille donc ça
doit être le bonheur de sa vie mais
c'est vrai qu'on se dit que tous les
jours ça doit être un combat pour lui
c'est effectivement un combat pour lui
tous les jours parce que bah au moins
sans mentir 3 5 fois par jour il
s'effondre en fait donc j'essaye d'être
là comme je peux j'essaye de le mener
vers le haut dans ce combat qui est très
difficile
mais avec sa fille il y a rien qui
change c'est son bonheur c'est ce qui
lui permet de s'évader en fait le temps
qu'il a avec sa fille qu'est-ce que tu
aimerais qui qui se passe pour tes
parents maintenant déjà j'aurais aimé
j'aurais mais déjà qui qui sortent pas
de chez eux aujourd'hui
en prison qui sont où là aujourd'hui ils
sont à leur domicile ils reçoivent
visite au sol puisque de leurs enfants
ont été placés voilà c'est ça mais pas
seul puisque leur famille côté de mon
père
leur rendre visite comme si comme si
rien ne s'était passé comme si ils
étaient de leur côté
j'aurais voulu pour mes parents voilà
comme j'ai dit qui ne sortent pas de
garde à vue qui sont amenés directement
en prison pour ce qu'ils ont fait
aujourd'hui ils sont ils sont jugés au
mois de janvier le 24 le 24 précisément
est une épreuve aussi pour vous tous ce
procès forcément mais ce qui nous choque
le plus tous autant que l'autre tout ce
temps que l'autre c'est que leur peine
maximum prévu pour eux et de deux
entreprises augmente et 30000 euros
d'amende incroyable sans savoir que les
30000 euros d'amende ne seront pas
condamnés ou sur mon compte d’années
mais pas payé car mes parents ne sont
pas redevables donc aucun argent sera
situé aux enfants victimes de et
aujourd'hui on ne veut pas d'argent
aujourd'hui on veut voir mes parents
souffrir comme vous vous avez souffert
ça sera pas ce point même si aujourd'hui
demain on est condamné à 15 20 ans j'ai
vécu très en torture peut-être pas j'ai
peut-être pas été l'enfant qui a pris le
plus de coups le plus d'insultes mais
voir ses frères et sœurs
victimes aussi de tout ça ça a été pour
moi de la torture encore ces dernières
semaines
pour moi de deux ans de prison on sait
très bien que aujourd'hui le dans
quelques mois le juge ne va pas les
condamnés à cette peine on va leur
mettre quoi
on va la remettre des travaux d'être les
généraux dans une crèche pour qu'ils
savent s'occuper des enfants
aujourd'hui
le procureur nous parle pas de en gros
de torture il dit que la maison
l'horreur c'est
s'aggraver je ne pense pas que que ce
monsieur je n'espère pas pour lui qui
l'ai vécu le quart de ce qu'on a vécu je
ne pense pas que ce monsieur aurait le
courage de t'accepter tous les coups que
mes petits frères et moi on a reçu je
pense pas qu'aujourd'hui ce monsieur
aurait le courage d'être là aujourd'hui
témoigner qu'on ne ses parents toute
leur qu'ils ont fait
je demande à ce monsieur de voir ses
propos parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a mis
tout tous mes frères et moi-même à terre
il nous a remis il nous a remis un coup
on avait déjà pris avec ces déclarations
qu'on va se battre qu'on va pas lâcher
et que on donnera tout pour que mes
frères et sœurs reçoivent l'amour qui
sont jamais eu la sécurité je demande à
ce genre de procureur de de jamais
jamais remettre les enfants dans dans
les dans les bras de mes parents mes
parents
de croiser le regard après tout ce qui
leur ont fait de condamner à hauteur de
ce qui nous ont fait tout simplement et
pas à deux ans de prison maximum
Bryan et Justine je vous souhaite
vraiment essayer d'avancer avec votre
petite fille de de trouver un moment le
bonheur que Brian est arrivé à ce chaude
il va avoir besoin de VOUS justiner
chaque vous êtes là pour lui et votre
petite fille aussi ça doit vraiment lui
faire du bien on espère aussi que cette
affaire à être prise au sérieux et c'est
vrai que des déclarations comme ça à la
télévision la procureur quand c'est pas
ce que va devenir l'affaire vous rendez
compte le mal que ça pu faire aux
enfants qui ont subi de telles sévices
et c'est aussi les dérives aujourd'hui
de la de la justice spectacle voilà
Brian en tout cas on va suivre cette
affaire Justine aussi et vous revenez
nous voir quand vous voulez pour donner
des nouvelles si vous avez besoin d'aide
quoi que ce soit on est là pour vous
aider merci Justine merci beaucoup